- Hello, everyone, I'm Saad Omer,
I'm the director of the Yale Institute
for Global Health also known as YGH,
and welcome to the YGH global
health conversation series.
This is a venue to learn
from, and connect with
innovative leaders in global health.
In addition to YGH, we're indebted to
the George Herbert Walker Jr. Lecture
at the Macmillan Center at Yale
for co-sponsoring today's event.
While we have seen progress,
significant challenges remain
in our global health response to COVID-19.
The pandemic continues to
take a devastating toll
in communities around the world,
and critically important issues
especially around equity,
and the availability of vaccines remain.
So if we were to beat back COVID-19,
we need to respond as a global community.
The World Health Organization,
as most of you know
plays a central role,
if not the central role,
in marshaling the global response
to the COVID-19 pandemic,
and many other critical health issues.
Over the next hour, we will
discuss a range of issues
including the importance
of ensuring equity
in tackling the pandemic,
the value and role of
the WHO in the world,
and, since we are connecting
from the U.S. at our side,
the importance of free engaging
the United States in the global response.
It is truly an honor for me
to introduce today's guests,
Dr. Tedros Adhanom Ghebreyesus,
he was elected the director
general of WHO in May, 2017
and is the first person
from the WHO African region
to head the world's leading
public health agency.
He has been a pioneer in global health,
well before his start with
WHO, as the director general,
he was born in Eritrean city of Asmara.
Dr. Tedros graduated from
the University of Asmara
with a Bachelor of Biology before earning
a Master of Science in
Immunology of Infectious Diseases
from the University of London,
a PhD in community health
from the University of Nottingham
and an Honorary Fellowship
from the London School
of Hygiene and Tropical Medicine.
Following his studies, Dr.
Tedros returned to Ethiopia
to support the delivery of health services
and doing some pioneering work
starting as a field level, malariologist,
before heading a regional health service
and later serving in
Ethiopia's federal government
for over a decade as minister of health
and minister of foreign affairs.
Under his leadership Ethiopia expanded
its health infrastructure,
developed innovative health
financing mechanisms,
and expanded its health workforce.
A particular, a major
component of reforms he drove,
was the creation of a primary
healthcare extension program
that deployed approximately 40,000
female health workers
throughout the country.
A significant result, was
an approximate 60% reduction
in child and maternal mortality,
compared to the 2,000 level.
So as minister of foreign
affairs from 2012 to 2016
he elevated health as a profession,
health as a political issue, nationally,
regionally as well as globally,
and in this role he led efforts
to negotiate Addis Ababa action agenda
in which now 193 countries committed
to the financing necessary to achieve
sustainable development goals.
Prior to his election as the DG for WHO
Dr. Tedros held many leadership
positions in global health,
including the chair of
the Global Health Fund
to fight AIDS, tuberculosis, and malaria,
chair of the Rollback Malaria Partnership,
and co-chair of the Partnership
for Maternal Newborn and Childhood Board.
After taking office as
the WHO director general,
in 2017 he initiated the most significant
organizational transformation
in that organization's history
which has generated a wide
range of achievements.
Welcome Dr. Tedros, we're so pleased
to have you here with us today,
and would love to start
with a few remarks from you.
- Thank you, thank you so
much Saad, can you hear me?
- Absolutely, loud and clear.
- Thank you, thank you my friend.
First of all, I'd like to
say I just started earlier
telling you, I have a very strong link
with Yale University.
That started when I was
minister of health in Ethiopia.
And the bridge was your own director
of global health at the time,
now she is the president
of Vassar College,
Dr. Elizabeth Bradley, I call her Betsy.
So we had a partnership, Yale University,
Clinton Foundation, and
Ethiopian Ministry of Health
on hospital reform.
But it didn't just stop there,
we cooperated on hospital reform,
and we had one of the biggest
reforms in Ethiopia together
the three of us, ministry
of health of Ethiopia,
Yale University and Clinton foundation.
And that was followed actually,
when I became foreign minister,
we continued the partnership
and we used to have
trainings organized by Yale,
you know, John Lewis
Gaddis on grand strategy
and training our diplomats
on grand strategy.
Of course, we use grand strategy also
for our reform in Ethiopia
with the support from
Betsy and John Gaddis.
And so I will stop there,
but I have many, many stories
I could have told you linked to Yale.
But I would like to thank Betsy
who has been the center, a
force of nature actually,
who helped in reforming the
health sector in Ethiopia.
But not only Betsy, I have many friends
and I would like to say, hello,
and greetings to all of you,
and I hope this pandemic
will be behind us,
and I will have a chance to
come to visit you at Yale.
And of course my sister, Betsy in Vassar,
I don't know if she's listening to this,
(laughing)
once Yale always Yale, so she might be.
Then greetings also to the
members and the students
of the Yale Institute for Global Health,
and to all the people
following this event online.
And thank you for the
opportunity to be with you today
and to discuss the critical
need for equitable access
to health services worldwide,
and the essential steps we
must take to achieve this.
First, I would like to
give a special thanks
to our moderator, my friend Saad Omer,
for his kind words as well as the support
he's providing WHO and the world
as a member of the WHO
technical advisory group
we call TAG, on behavioral insights
which is actually a new addition
and part of the transformation in WHO.
This independent expert
group is advising WHO
on understanding the many factors
that affect people
behaviors and practices,
which is vital for helping countries
design more equitable health
policies and programs.
Of course, the chair is professor Cass,
and they were working
with Saad very closely
professor Cass from Harvard.
This is the type of work that's critical
to WHO's efforts to
advance health for all.
Which includes not only
universal health coverage,
but also the social, environmental,
and economic policies and
factors that affect health.
As COVID-19 has harshly
illustrated equity matters.
This pandemic has thrived
amid the inequalities and
inequities in our societies
and exploited the gaps
in our health systems.
It has exacerbated the disparities
between and within countries.
But while the pandemic
has affected all of us,
the poorest and most marginalized
have been hit hardest.
Both in terms of lives
and livelihoods lost.
The impact of the COVID-19 crisis
pushed an estimated 120 million people
into extreme poverty last year.
Gender inequalities have
significantly increased
with more women than men
leaving the labor force.
And as we speak, rich
countries are vaccinating
their populations while the
world's poor watch and wait.
As you may know high and
upper-middle income countries,
which account for 53% of
the world's population,
have administered 83%
of the world's vaccines.
Meanwhile, low and lower
middle income countries
which make up 47% of the world's people,
have received just 17%
of the world's vaccines.
The inequitable distribution
of vaccines is a moral outrage.
It's also economically and
epidemiologically self-defeating.
As COVID-19 has shown,
the pandemic is more than a health crisis.
It has had grave
consequences for livelihoods,
businesses, and economies.
The pandemic has shown that
when health is at risk,
everything is at risk.
But when health is protected and promoted,
individuals, families, communities,
economies and nations can thrive.
Health should not be seen as a cost,
but as an investment in
productive, resilient
and inclusive societies.
But globally, as you're observing,
we're going in the wrong direction.
Around the world, more
households are spending
an increasing proportion
of their income on health.
And more people are
being exposed to poverty
as a result of out of
pocket health spending.
It's clear that making progress
toward this universal health coverage,
cannot just be a matter
for ministries of health,
but takes an all of government approach
with leadership from the
highest political levels.
At the United Nations
general assembly in 2019,
just a few months before
the pandemic started,
UN member states endorsed the high level
political declaration on
universal health coverage.
We must learn the
lessons of this pandemic.
and build on the political
momentum for equity
to mobilize investments for healthier,
more resilient, and more
sustainable societies.
In closing, I would like to
offer a few things to consider,
as you move forward in your studies,
and your careers in global health.
First, remember that health
is part of a larger ecosystem
that encompasses environmental,
social, economic and political factors.
That's why it's important
for health professionals
and policy makers to take
a multi-sectoral approach.
Don't be afraid to work
across disciplines.
Partnerships can make us stronger
and achieve the desired result.
Second, search for examples
of what works in countries,
and communities around the world.
Reverse engineer them and
see what might inspire
further research leading
to tangible global change.
And best practices can
be found everywhere.
In high-income countries,
low-income countries,
middle income countries.
And the pandemic has shown us that.
Even the countries, the
high-income countries
were very vulnerable.
And third, let's rethink
that narrative around health.
Not as a cost, but as an
investment in our common future.
Strong health systems and
global health security,
are two sides of the same coin.
Now, let's get started
with our discussion,
I'm looking forward to your questions.
Thank you again, Professor
Saad Omer, and back to you.
- Thank you, and thanks for
the kind words about Yale
and your previous
interaction and collaboration
and work with this institution.
You know, since you
mentioned Betsy Bradley,
she and I had a chat a few
weeks ago around an event,
and she was very much planning to attend
and she's likely to be
listening in and streaming this.
So rest assured one of your
old friends is very much here,
is likely to be here,
I haven't confirmed it,
but she was intending to attend.
So I think, you know, thanks
for laying out this vision
for an equitable future in health.
But focusing on the more short term,
how do we as a global
community work towards
equitable access to vaccines, treatments,
and other health services
in this pandemic?
- No, thank you, thank you very much.
I think what's key in
especially ensuring equitable
access is political commitment.
And that political commitment
should actually emanate
from a belief that sharing or cooperation,
sharing of vaccine, that's cooperation,
is in the interest of
every individual country.
So any country you name
should believe that
the vaccine equity is
good to end this pandemic,
and it's in the interest of all of us
or in the interest of every nation.
I can give you one example for instance,
you know, new variants are appearing.
I know many countries are moving
especially high income
countries are moving
with high vaccination coverage.
Some of them may achieve 70 or 80%
by summer or end of this year.
But if the rest of the
world remains unvaccinated
or low coverage like what we see now, 0.3%
in low-income countries,
then the new variants
will continue to mutate,
and then you may find
variance that may actually
evade the vaccines that
are already being used.
Then those countries who believe
that they have already high
coverage will be affected
because there is a new guy, a new virus,
mutated significantly means a new one,
it's almost like new, that
will again affect them.
So they are doing it
for their own interests
and I think that understanding will help
in vaccine equity nothing
else, to be honest.
And the second, maybe
to see the other way,
this is a common enemy.
And unless we fight it together,
unless we fight it in unison,
it will not be defeated.
And if we are divided
it will use the divisions to attack us.
So if we're divided,
we're more vulnerable.
If we work in unison, then we will be able
to defeat this virus and end the pandemic
as soon as possible.
So it's a must, actually the
only way to end this pandemic
is through cooperation.
So that's it, it's really
realizing this issue
that will, I mean, realizing
this, that will help us.
And then of course, I understand
there are some concerns,
for instance, the private sector.
I think we need to put
people before profits.
And we have to make a choice.
Because making profits
will be at the expense
of losing many lives and at the expense
of extending the pandemic.
So, I mean, it's very clear
for those who want to act.
And then of course, if there
is political commitment
then you move into increasing
production capacity by waving IP.
For instance, if you
believe that, you know
people come first before profit,
then you waive IP and
you take other measures
like technology transfer and
so on to increase production,
have enough supplies to share.
But to make that happen
you will need also money.
So you need to mobilize resources.
As we speak Now we need
19 billion U.S. dollars
for ACT Accelerator, but
we are not getting it.
Of course, U.S. has contributed
4 billion U.S. dollars
but still there is a gap.
But as you know many high income countries
are already spending a lot of money
for their stimulus package.
19 billion compared to
the stimulus package
is a very small amount of money.
So if there is real commitment
which I say the political commitment,
then the financing should also come
because the increased production capacity
cannot come without financing.
So if we do political commitment
and that means we'll be followed
by taking every action
to increase production
and then to increase production
we will need financing
if we do those and if
we identify this virus
as a common enemy and it's
in the interest of all of us
I think the vaccine equity can be done.
Thank you and back to you.
- No, I think thanks for
highlighting the value
of global engagement with WHO.
Switching to the US, what is
that partnership look like
moving forward, and then what explicitly
is needed from your perspective
from the Biden administration
to fulfill the promise of WHO
and the multilateral system?
- Yeah, thank you so much.
First of all, I would like to start
by thanking the Biden administration.
As you may remember, during
the election campaign,
he promised to reverse the
former administration's decision
that they, office inauguration.
So he signed a letter
actually on January 20th
that reverses the decision.
So he kept his promise.
And second, I had a call on 21st January
the day I received the letter
from his excellency the president,
I received a call from vice
president Kamala Harris
and, you know on U.S.
commitment to work with WHO
and to help global health.
And then, third, I had a call
with the same day actually
there was a presentation
to our board by Tony Fauci.
And then of course I had a call
after the secretary of
health was appointed
with secretary Xavier Becerra,.
You can see the strong commitment
and I have to really appreciate that.
And what I expect is what
the Biden administration
is saying now.
For the US to be in WHO
is good for the U.S.,
good for the U.S., and
good for the U.S. citizens
and good for the rest of
the world, and good for WHO.
So, joining WHO, working with WHO
is in the interest of the U.S.
Biden administration believes this
and we believe that by the way.
And it's in the interest
of the rest of the world.
That mentality is important
because it's the mindset
that leads you to effective partnership.
So the mindset of this
administration is, U.S. benefits,
the rest of the world benefits
if the U.S. engages WHO.
That's very important, and that's why
they're doing what they're doing now
and which we were
expecting, joining COVAX,
supporting COVAX with
4 billion U.S. dollars,
and also, you know, activating
all the program support
they have been providing
us, the financial support,
and working with us very
closely, not only to fight COVID,
but to fight other diseases as well.
Yeah, so this is what
we have been expecting,
and we see that that's happening
and we will continue to work with the U.S.
very, very closely and, you
know have better outcome
in the fight against this pandemic,
but at the same time
in other programs, too.
- Wonderful.
So, you know, more than
two dozen countries
and the European Council
president have signed a statement
calling for the creation of
a new international treaty
for pandemic preparedness and response.
What should be the key
elements of this treaty
and your overall perspective on the treaty
and on what should be the WHO's role?
- Yeah, thank you.
As you know, before the
pandemic many people,
many institutions,
including WHO are saying
the world is unprepared for a pandemic.
And what we see now is exactly that.
And not the only we were saying
the world it is unprepared
but we weren't proposing
solutions or actions,
but I think action was late,
and that's why the pandemic
is now wrecking havoc.
And we now know, how unprepared we were,
and we now know what
the major problems were,
more than ever before.
Of course we knew them,
but even the hardest way
we know now.
And the problems are
poor national capacity
in emergency preparedness and response.
And at the same time,
poor global capacity.
When there is poor, or
weak national capacity,
it makes us vulnerable as a globe.
And our strength is as
strong as the weakest link.
Or we are globally as
weak as the weakest link.
Unless we address the
weaknesses that we have.
So this is very clear now,
and the investment should stop
from building national capacity,
and the pandemic treaty can help.
Maybe if I go to specific
other challenges problems
that are common factor,
be it as national capacity
or global capacities, for instance,
we have seen weaknesses in sharing better.
Very serious problem.
There are problems in sharing pathogens
or biological material.
And there is a problem in
sharing technology like vaccines,
we just, we have been discussing,
and there is a problem in
sharing resources like financing.
Financing, preparedness and response.
So we believe that the pandemic treaty
which we are now pushing
for, can address this gaps.
Without sharing information,
you can not fight
an outbreak, epidemic or pandemic.
That has to be addressed
without sharing the pathogens
and if there is a problem
in sharing pathogens and you know,
all the problems associated with that.
And without sharing vaccines,
now you see the disparity
and the virus is continuing to wreck havoc
throughout the world.
So we believe the pandemic
treaty can address
this specific weaknesses
among other things.
Of course, the pandemic
treaty is not all about
these five things I raised.
It's more than that, but these are
some of the critical ones.
So national capacity, global
capacity, sharing information,
sharing pathogens for biological material,
sharing technology like vaccines,
and sharing resources and strings
and the whole global
preparedness and response.
That's what the pandemic treaty can do.
And there is an opportunity
now because of the pandemic
and let's use this
pandemic as an opportunity.
Like as the saying goes, use
every crisis as an opportunity.
If we're going to use this
crisis as an opportunity,
then the solution, pandemic
treaty that addresses
the major weaknesses we
had, is very important,
and something that we can
pass to our children and grandchildren.
- So before the pandemic,
right before the pandemic
and if I can sort of
editorialize a little bit,
just in time for the pandemic,
you launched an initiative
to transform the
secretariat, transform WHO.
So there's been a lot of,
you know public discussion
as there is in these
kinds of situations about,
you know, how the pandemic will
impact WHO's transformation.
So what are your thoughts on it?
And as one would think that,
if it ain't broke, don't fix
it, in terms of certain aspects
while other aspects might
require some change,
what is your perspective on
that kind of a discussion?
- Yeah, thank you.
I mean, that's a very important question.
You know, I will take you back actually,
when I was running for my campaign
for this position, for DG,
one of the priorities, four priorities,
one of them was emergency
preparedness and response.
And then as soon as I was elected,
the first major speech I had
was on pandemic preparedness and response.
And that was in Columbia
University in September, 2017.
September, 2017, and I was
asked to choose, you know,
whatever area I would like to speak about
and I said pandemic preparedness.
And I told actually the audience a story
and how that started in the
U.S. and then in a military camp
in the West, and then how that traveled
to the East in New York, you know,
well even started coming to transmission
and across the Atlantic to Europe.
I didn't tell them what it was.
But that was just telling the story
and how many people were
killed, and then I told them
the same thing can happen
now, this happened in 1918,
but the same thing can happen now.
Then of course we started the
design of the transformation
and because it was my election promise.
So one of the pillars was emergency,
and we started actually building things
that are very important
for emergency preparedness
and response, not only
the talk in Columbia,
the first major speech I had
as a DG, after I became DG,
but that was real, our fear was real,
and that's why I made it
part of the transformation.
And we established as a
result of the transformation,
new emergency preparedness
division, just for preparedness.
And then a new science division,
with the first ever chief
scientist was established.
And of course, data, we pulled
all data functions together
and we articulated with
clarity, some of the changes
we need to make in order to help
with emergency preparedness but of course
the rest of the programs.
Also WHO Academy, to help us with training
because you need to build capacity.
And that's very, very important.
And of course other things, I
don't want to waste your time
and the time of our audiences,
students by listing all.
But most of the things we had done
as part of our transformation
were very relevant
for emergency response.
Actually, we used those
to fight the pandemic.
Although these things
were done just few months
before the pandemic, but
they were very helpful
in many ways.
I wish we had more time.
(laughing)
It was like immediate.
And now, from what I see
it's a matter of building
on what we have started.
And the other very important
element in our transformation
was to make WHO a learning organization.
To make change constant,
meaning we will take
the recommendations from
the different panels,
from the IPPR, from the IHR
review committee, from IOC,
from other platforms, even
if you have crazy ideas
from your university
which I'm really close to,
give us, this pandemic is unprecedented.
It has affected everybody,
everybody on earth, every life.
So we need to listen
and accommodate that and
continue to change WHO.
So we have started, why
transformation is important.
We have started that
transformation journey, I mean,
and we know why
transformation is important
but we even know that
change should be a constant
and we should accommodate change
and recalibrate and reposition
WHO, of course the whole
global capacity on regular basis.
So there is no problem that we started.
We started something that's helpful
for emergency preparedness and response.
It's a matter of building on it
but we need to accommodate more.
This is unprecedented, so
we should do even more.
We should even change
things more significantly
than it is now.
- That's wonderful and thanks
for being open to ideas.
That's a great of looking at
it, sort of how, as a globe,
we learned from this
experience and just as an aside
Yale is well represented
in some of these things,
as you know, professor Ernesto Zedillo,
former president of
Mexico is a Yale professor
and is a part of the IPPR.
So there is, you know, that input.
So switching to the audience questions
and we are getting some
very interesting questions.
And one question, I think you
briefly touched upon that,
but you might wanna expand on that
because of the specificity of the question
and this, you know
questionnaire acknowledges,
questioner acknowledges that,
or highlights the disjointed
nature of the global response
from various countries and other entities,
private or public.
Is there one specific
item that jumps to mind
as the most critical step
we as a global community could take
to minimize such
discontinuity in the future?
- Can you rephrase the question?
- So, (coughing)
the premise of the question
is that there has been some
discontinuity in the response
by various countries and
private and public entities.
Is there a single step or
sort of a finite set of steps
that come to your mind
that would prevent that
from happening in terms
of a disjointed response
from happening in future pandemics
and large public health emergencies?
- Yeah, so when you say
disjointed, are you talking
about global or at country level?
- I'm talking about
global, between countries.
- So you're mean no
uniformity in response.
- Exactly, so no uniformity,
so Europe's response,
not harmonized with the U.S.
response and the response
and sort of various countries
implementing strategies
that has have global
implications, even for example
on supply chains for
vaccines and treatment
non-pharmaceutical interventions
and so on and so forth.
And so that fragmentation
perhaps hasn't served us well.
Is there anything, first of
all, feel free to question
the premise of this
question, but if you do agree
that there has been this
fragmented response this time
by various countries, are there mechanisms
that come to your mind that
could help prevent that?
- Yeah, thank you, thank you very much.
First of all, I don't think
it would be a surprise
to the students, but
I'll tell you one thing.
Those who were not listening are actually
the high-income countries.
(laughing)
Because they think that they have
the best system on earth.
So they don't listen to WHO.
But WHO has experts that come
from different countries.
So no country can claim that
it has better capacity than WHO
because we are a collection
of diverse experiences
and capacities that could be
better than any single country,
and advice from WHO is
like a collective advice
from a center that
accommodates all the experience
and practices of many countries.
So, I think that's one,
meaning, the high-income countries
should take WHO seriously.
And when WHO advises, they should listen.
You may remember, some high
income countries when we said
this virus is very
dangerous, they were saying,
"Oh, it's flu, we can manage it."
When we say this virus is
Public Enemy Number One,
in February last year, maybe you remember,
they were saying, "No, no,
no, we can let it circulate.
"and then there could be herd immunity
"by letting it circulate freely,
and then we will be okay."
We fought back saying,
"No, it's not a flu.
"It's a very dangerous virus,
it's very transmittable,
"it's a killer.
"It has these two dangerous combinations,
"that's why we call it
public enemy number one."
And sadly the high income countries
were not taking it seriously
because they believe
that they have better capacity.
That's very important by the way.
And then of course, even
if you don't categorize
by high, middle and low income countries,
the many countries because
of many other reasons
that they were not following the advisers.
So going forward, what do we
do to address this problem?
That's why we're saying pandemic treaty.
There will be areas that
will address, you know,
the important elements that the country
should really observe, all
countries whether they are high,
middle, or low income countries,
and accommodating it
in the pandemic treaty
would be very, very important.
But even in the absence of
the pandemic treaty now,
uniformity of action or
response is very important.
Because when there is uniformity,
and when all countries
do the same thing at the same time,
the virus will not get
a space to maneuver.
And very simple and
anybody can understand it.
You deny the virus a space to
maneuver when you act as one.
That's why we have been
calling for cooperation,
that's why we have been
asking for solidarity.
We have been proposing
actions, public health,
and we have been saying, please do it all,
because we knew that the
same action everywhere
could actually stop or slow the virus.
So going forward, I
think institutionalizing
the solutions will be important.
And the pandemic treaty will be one
that will institutionalize,
and then of course,
both high-income and
low-income or all categories,
high, middle, upper middle, low income,
should listen to a multi-lateral
organization like WHO.
We have been consistent
on this as you know.
Although the virus was new
and there could be some things
we didn't know, we started by
saying, "We don't know this,
"but this is what we think you should do."
And then we started to learn together
and we know better now and going forward
I think that uniform action
will be very, very important.
Back to you Saad.
- Yeah, no, thank you.
And so there's another
question from the audience
about the fact that global
health funding has been reactive
rather than sustained and sustainable.
So, and you very nicely
sort of talked about
learning from crises to move forward.
So how do we ensure going forward
that governments and
donors are held accountable
to long-term impactful
funding for health equity?
- Yeah, and thank you so much.
I mean, if we are going
to address that problem,
that problem is very visible as you said,
we have to get out of this
panic and neglect cycle.
So we always move in a
vicious cycle, you know,
panic, neglect, panic, neglect, okay?
There is an epidemic or outbreak,
we panic, we react, we finance,
and then as soon as that's taken care of
then we neglect and so on.
So we have to recognize health threats
as a cornerstone threat.
And the same thing can happen anytime.
So the world should be
prepared anytime, at all times.
Treat it like for instance
a security problem.
Countries, you know, the budgets they have
for their defense or security,
it's big and it's sustainable.
And I think they have
seen how health actually
impacts even more than a terrorist
because they prepare that
because maybe because they have a threat
from their neighbors or beyond,
they prepare because of fear of terrorism,
but the virus I think has
shown that it has more impact
than what we fear.
It has impacted our economy,
it has impacted us politically,
socially, you name it.
And the whole world has
been taken actually hostage.
I have never seen since
the second world war
if there is anything that has
really frozen the whole world.
Even second world war
some parts were okay.
So it affected everything,
and it has shown that health is centered.
So if we cannot finance it sustainably,
then I think there is
something wrong with us.
We are not listening.
I think it's enough to listen now.
More than enough.
We were affected the hard way.
So I think we have listened,
and that's what I believe,
and there should be a
significant investment.
And for sustainability of funding,
where I would have start
is, if we realize that
health is central and
we don't want anything
like this to happen,
then the simple answer
is we have to believe in
universal health coverage.
We should stop commercializing health.
Health is it not a commodity for sale.
Health should it be taken
as a human rights issue.
Like a foundation.
And one ask I have is,
each and every country
to put it in its constitution
as a fundamental human rights issue.
And commit to health for all,
and do whatever, even
the poorest on earth,
whatever to keep its people healthy,
to strengthen its system.
You know, what UK did because I just want,
I don't want any country
to have any excuses.
The UK decided on NHS immediately after
the Second World War.
Lord Beveridge, when its
economy was in tatters,
it decided to have health
for all, that's NHS.
So no country can have any excuse.
So if we want this not to happen again
I don't see it as financing
only, and meaning finance it,
then I think that level of commitment
will be very important.
Health is central, health for all,
we should move toward this health for all,
and take it, even recognize
it in our constitution.
Many countries have done that,
and all countries should do that.
And they shouldn't commercialize health.
When I say this, by the
way I have to be clear.
I'm not saying private
sector should not be involved
and everything should be public,
what I'm saying is government
should take responsibility
and the services can be
provided through government,
public or private sector,
or what do you call it,
a hybrid or one of
them, it doesn't matter,
it's up to the country to choose.
But I think the government
spending, I mean, contribution
is very, very important and government
should take responsibility
to make this happen.
So that's how we can address
the sustainability of financing.
Then globally, if we do this
locally at national level,
then sustaining global
efforts will not be a problem.
And for that, the recommendations we have
is global financing.
Let's not try to have new
institutions for global financing.
Even for local, by the way.
We can use IMF, we can use The World Bank,
we can use the regional banks,
of course they should develop
some flexible processes,
very agile processes,
and then commitment to pandemic
preparedness and response,
but the existing institutions can do it.
Thank you, sorry, I
took a long on this one
because it's very important.
- No, I agree and it's nuanced.
So as we reach sort of the
last part of our conversation,
so I wanna highlight another
question from the audience.
As you know that in pandemics
and large public health emergencies
the evidence base is changing.
So the question is, is there
a way, is there a creative way
for global universities to
be more directly helpful
to the WHO when its needs are
acute for all evidence-based
reviews and rapid responses?
You know, the collaborating
center model is very much there
but as you know, that it takes time
and often new players are
needed and agility is needed
in public health emergencies.
So is there, you know, for example,
the questionnaire suggests,
you know, is there a value
of a master contract that
doesn't involve a lot of money
or perhaps even no money
but there is a framework
for rapid synthesis of evidence,
so the intellectual
capacity that is out there
can be fully marshaled.
So we'd love to hear
your thoughts on that,
especially as you know,
one of the agenda you have
within WHO is the WHO Academy
so this capacity building,
this focus on evidence, is I think in line
with this kind of question
in a potential proposal.
- Thank you, I think you read my mind.
I was going to say, "Oh, we
have collaborating centers,"
but you preempted by saying,
"I know about collaborating centers, so."
(laughing)
This is by the way, we
believe in networks.
We have several networks there're,
some of them university based,
some of them, other institutional based,
but from the way you
said, the master contract,
it doesn't mean it involves
money of universities.
I think network of those
would be very important.
Why not you develop this as a concept.
What I like about Yale
is the grand strategy,
that's where you process
and bring new ideas.
So I see this as a new idea
with just purely universities.
And we don't go into that
process of collaborating centers
but a different way of
partnership with universities,
both in the South and North,
everywhere all over the world.
Low income, high income, middle income.
And if you can develop a
concept with your students
and we would be happy to have
a followup discussion on this
but I think this may evolve as a good way
of partnership with WHO.
Thank you so much for that.
- Wonderful, so the last question--
- And then we have the WHO Academy,
but the partnership with Universities
may not be just for training.
It could be other things, that's why
it could be more than training.
Of course the WHO Academy
starts with training
but for the future, it
will have a research arm.
So that could be the center, by the way,
to coordinate all the opportunities
that we can have globally.
By the way, the WHO Academy is also new.
It's an outcome of the transformation
and it can also take part in here.
But that's a very good
idea, I would be happy
if you can develop it further
and have a follow-up meeting.
- So, one last question
before we wrap up is,
that as we move beyond the pandemic
and you have vociferously
advocated from the beginning,
even before you took charge of WHO
about the universal health care agenda.
How do we, so the pandemic will
subside one way or another,
we will have to be ready for the next one.
How do we reengage or even
engage with more vigor
in the universal health care
agenda in the next few years?
- Yeah, I think this is
very, very important.
We are already saying to
the international community
what I just said earlier, and
now, because of this pandemic,
we know how central health is.
And that investing in
universal health coverage
is the answer.
And the pandemic itself has
already, what do you call it,
strengthened the case for
health for all, or UHC.
So we have already started engaging
but we will continue to even do it more.
But the messages are exactly
what I told you earlier,
what I said earlier.
Meaning if you ask me one
thing, very concrete thing
that countries can do, if they can put it,
their commitment could be
put in their constitution,
UHC or health for all.
So we have a specific ask now to make,
and to ask countries when we engage,
when we continue to engage
that they should put it
in their constitution
because that's actually
how you would know how
committed a country is
when they put it in their constitution.
So it made it easier for
us now to explain why,
health is central.
It's very tragic, all that happened,
more than 3.2 million
people have died already,
because of this pandemic,
but it has shown us
beyond any doubt, the
centrality of health.
So there is already good
opportunity to push the agenda
and look forward to working with you,
to push the health for all,
or the universal health coverage agenda.
- Thank you very much, and as
we wrap up this conversation
I wanna thank you, Dr. Tedros
for being a passionate advocate
for universal health care
and very specifically health equity for
well before this pandemic, and I know
based on that track record
that you will continue to be
an advocate for global health equity.
And thank you for working
with the fierce urgency of now
to paraphrase, to borrow a phrase
from Martin Luther King Jr, that you know,
which was required in this pandemic.
And I think WHO's response, the
global response has shown us
the indispensable nature
of institutions like WHO,
and that these institutions matter.
It matter from Kansas to Katmandu,
because we all use one or another function
that WHO fulfills, the convening function
or the technical guidance
function benefits us all,
and it is in our interest to make sure
that these institutions and
specifically WHO is healthy
and continues to move forward.
So thank you very much
for taking the time,
we really appreciate you being here today.
- Thank you, thank you so much, Saad,
and I would appreciate it if
you can also pass my greetings
to John Gaddis, eh?
- I will, absolutely.
- I hope you will find ways to (mumbles)
you can catch him, yeah?
(both laughing)
So, thank you, thank you so much, bye-bye.